نقلت صحيفه واشنطن بوست عن مسؤول امريكيه
ان مديره وكاله الاستخبارات المركزيه
الامريكيه ويليام التقى الشهر الماضي في
كييف الرئيس فلودي ميرسي واضفت الصحيفه ان
بيرنز اطلع خلال الزياره السريه التي سبقت
صعيد في روسيا طلع على خطط اوكرانيا
لاستعاده اراضيها التي تحتلها روسيا
تمهيدا لدفعها الى التفاوض بحلول نهايه
العام
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم كان ذاك خبر حلقتنا ولنا في
نقاشه ثلاثه مسارات ما الذي يمكن قراءته
في زياره بيرز السريه لكييف وتوقيتها من
خلال المعلومات المتوفره عنها وما دلاله
بحثها خطط واهداف العسكريه في الفتره
المقبله وما ملامح ومرتكزات خطط اوكرانيا
للمرحله المقبله وفق ما عرضه زيلينسكي على
بيرلز وما مدى امكانيه تاثر هذه الخطط
بالتطورات الاخيره في روسيا
وما مدى واقعيه حديث كييف عن تحقيق نجاح
عسكري من اجل دفع موسكو للتفاوض وكيف
ستتعاطى روسيا مع هذا المسار بالنظر
للتغيرات السياسيه والميدانيه المستجده
[موسيقى]
على لسان مسؤول امريكي اشترط عدم الكشف عن
هويته نقل صحيفه واشنطن بوست ان مدير
وكاله الاستخبارات المركزيه الامريكيه
ويليامبرز زارا اوكرانيا سرا في وقت سابق
من الشهر الماضي المسؤول الامريكي اضاف
بحسب الصحيفه ان زياره بانز التي سبقت
صعيد قوات فاجنر تضمنت اجتماعات مع الرئيس
فلودي مرزيلنسكي وكبار مسؤولين
الاستخبارات الاوكرانيه واضاف المصدر ان
المسؤولين الاوكرانيين كشفوا لبيرز
استراتيجيتهم لاستعاده الاراضي التي
تحتلها روسيا تمهيدا لدفعها الى مفاوضات
وقف اطلاق نار بحلول نهايه العام وابلغ
المسؤول الامريكي الصحيفه بحسب ما ذكرت
تاكيد مسؤولا اوكرانيا رفيع قناعه كييف
بان موسكو لن تتفاوض الا اذا شعرت
بالتهديد واكد المسؤول ايضا ان بيرز لم
يناقش في كيف اكتشفته واشنطن قبيل ذلك عن
تخطيط مالك فاجنر لما سماه هجوما من نوع
ما بحسب واشنطن بوست
[موسيقى]
لمناقشه هذا الموضوع معنا من اوس كبير
الباحثين في المعهد الاوكراني للدراسات
الاستراتيجيه وننتظر ان ينضم الينا من
موسكو الكسندر ارثمنوف الخبير في الشؤون
العسكريه والدوليه ومن واشنطن الدكتور
خليل العناني استاذ العلوم السياسيه
والعلاقات الدوليه مرحبا بكم جميعا
الدكتور عناني ابدا معك هل ترى اي خصوصيه
في زياره
وليمبرز الى كييف خاصه من حيث التوقيت ومن
حيث مجريات
الحرب الروسيه الاوكرانيه وتباطؤ الهجوم
داخل
اوكرانيا الهجوم المضاد وبالاضافه الى ما
جرى داخليا في روسيا
انا اعتقد هناك عده امور تقف في خلفيه
زياره بيرنز الى اوكرانيا للامر الاول
المتعلق بالوقوف على اخر تطورات الهجوم
المضاد او الكونترفنس الذي كان المفترض ان
يبدا قبل شهرين وتاخر نتيجه لعدم امداد
اوكرانيا
بالاسلحه المطلوبه حسب طبعا ما تقول
اوكرانيا ايضا عدم وصول المتدربين هناك
عدد من الجنود الاوكرانيين تدربوا في
عواصم غربيه وبالتالي كان هناك حاجه
لعودتهم ثم البدء اللي هو المضاد الامر
الثاني متعلق بمناقشه تطورات هذا الهجوم
خاصه فيما يتعلق بان هناك حاله بطء واضح
جدا وهناك التمام من الغرب من هذه المساله
وبالامس هناك تصريح مهم جدا لجنرال
المشترك الامريكيه الذي قال بانه الهجوم
الاوكراني المضاده على روسيا هو يمر او
يعني يتم بشكل بطيء وسيكون دموي الى حد
بعيد الامر الثاني متعلق بامكانيه معرفه
سقف التفاوض الاوكراني خاصه هناك يعني سعي
في هذه المساله بمعنى اخر هل هناك لا يزال
تمسك اوكراني بما طرحه الرئيس لدسك قبل
حوالي الان اخر العام الماضي فيما يعرف
بخطه النقاط العشر التي يتمسك فيها
بالسعاده كافه الاراضي الاوكرانيه المحتله
سواء بعد الحرب التي بدات قبل عام ونصف من
الان او التي احتلت عام 2014 فيما يتعلق
باحتلال جزيره القرم في خلفيه زياره ايضا
الامر يتعلق بما يبدو تمنون امريكيا من
ارتفاع تكلفه الحرب في اوكرانيا حتى لم
نتكلم على الاقل على 54 مليار دولار تم
صرفها حتى هذه اللحظه سواء فيما يتعلق
بشكل معاناه اقتصاديه او دعم عسكري او دعم
استخبارات الامر الاخر ايضا متعلق على ما
يبدو هناك حاجه لحسب هذا الموضوع قبل بدء
الموسم الانتخابي في امريكا في العام
المقبل وبالتالي هناك حاجه امريكيه
للتاكيد على انه اوكرانيا لا تصبح نقطه
ضعف فيما يتعلق بالديمقراطيين في
الانتخابات المقبله خاصه في ظل استغلال
ترامب هذه المساله والهجوم على اداره
بايدن فيما يتعلق بعدم قدرتها على حسب
الصراع مع امي كثيرا تقع في الزياره حتى
هذه اللحظه على الاقل
من حاله التحرك التي قادها في الرابع
والعشرين من الشهر الفائت في يونيو حزيران
عدم اعطاء الطرف
الاوكراني اي معلومات ومشاركته فيها الا
يعني ذلك بان هناك مسافه لا زالت بين ما
يفترض حليفين في حرب مهمه كهذه الحرب بين
واشنطن وكيف تحديدا
نحن ابعد بالطبع في العلاقات لذلك قضيه ان
مدير
المخابرات المركزيه بما انه لم يقدم هذه
المعلومات لاوكرانيا هذا يدل على ان
مستوى الثقه قد يكون ليس عاليا او ربما
لانهم لم ينشروا المعلومات حتى على اكثر
الشركاء قربا لهم
اعتقد انه من الصعب لامريكا ان تقوم
بتقديم هذه المعلومات لاوكرانيا عندما لم
تقم بتقديمها للاخرين
سيد دكتور خليل عناني هل تتفق مع مثل هذه
الرؤيه يعني حسابات التحالف بين واشنطن في
مثل هذه الحرب التي صرفت عليها الكثير من
الاموال وعولت عليها في استراتيجيات
رسمتها واشنطن
للنيتو للدول الاوروبيه وايضا ضمن علاقتها
مع روسيا
بعدم هذه المشاركه لهذه المعلومات حول
ما جرى في الرابع والعشرين داخل روسيا امر
عادي وربما هو معقول بالنسبه لي العلاقات
الدوليه التي تحكم مثل هذه الامور
انا اعتقد هناك عدد امور في هذه المساله
الامر الاول المتعلق بانه امريكا نفسها
تفاجات بشكل او اخر بدات تحرك السريع نعم
كانت هناك معلومات لدى الانتخابات
الامريكيه على الاقل منذ يوم الاربعاء
السابقه على التمرد لكن كانت معلومات بشكل
عام لا تنبئ بوجود تحرك سريع كان هناك
معلومات تدل ان هناك حاله تململ حاله يعني
تعبئه وحشد من قبل
بروجين فيما يتعلق بامكانيه تواجه ولكنه
تحرك بشكل سريع فجاه الجميع ولذلك كان
هناك تحفظ الامريكي كما نعلم جميعا بعد
القيام بهذه العمليه حتى لا تبدو انك
مطارده بشكل او باخر حتى لا تستغل من قبل
روسيا بوصف ما حدث من تمرد باعتباره
مؤامره غربيه كما العاده فيما يتعلق بخطاب
بوتين الخارجي لكن ايضا هناك بالبلا شك
هناك حاله تبادل المعلومات قوي بين
الطرفين فيما يتعلق بتنسيق لوجستي تنسيق
استخباراتي لانه كما نعلم جميعا ليست حرب
قرانيه روسيه هذه حرب روسيه غربيه هناك
كما قلت
حلت دعم غير محدود هذه تعتبر اطول حتى هذه
اللحظه الحرب العالميه الثانيه التي تجري
في اوروبا على مطار اكثر من 16 شهر حتى
هذه اللحظه وبالتالي هناك حاله بشبه
التوحد ما بين القوى الغربيه خاصه اوروبا
وامريكا وامريكا فيما يتعلق بهذه الحرب
وبالتالي من الصعب القهوه ليس هناك تبادل
هذه المعلومات بشكل او باخر لم يكن الامر
بهذه السهوله كان هناك كما قلت قبل قليل
حاله عنصر مفاجاه للجميع وبالتالي من
الصعب مشاركه معلومات قد تكون غير كامله
تؤثر بشكل او باخر على حاله الرجوع
المضاده تكون بها اوكرانيا فيما يتعلق
بدفع روسيا الى الخلف في مناطق الشرقيه
لحدودها مع روسيا طيب سيد
ابرز ايضا عنه ضمن هذه الزي
اره ضمن الرؤيه الاوكرانيه هي عمليه
استعاده
يعني اراضي في الشرق الاوكراني وفي الجنوب
بالاضافه الى تشكيل عمليه تهديد اوكرانيا
حقيقيه لشبه جزيره القرم من اجل دفع روسيا
للذهاب الى التفاوض والجلوس الى طاوله
التفاوض كما خططت لها في نهايه هذا العام
هل مثل هذه الخطط هي خطط اوكرانيه محضى
والى اي درجه هناك
بحسب رايك موافقه امريكيه على مثل هذا
النهج الاوكراني
تقوم بالتنسيق في اعمالها وخططها ولكن هذا
لا يعني اننا بدرجه مئه بالمئه نقوم
باحاطه شركائنا بخططنا نعم نتحدث اننا
ننوي القيام بخطوات معينه
وحسب ما قال واشنطن بوست اوكرانيا كانت
تريد ان تنجح في الجبهات ثم ان تبدا في
المفاوضات ولكن انا لا اصدق شخصيا ان هناك
اي طرف من الاطراف مستعد للمفاوضات على
الاقل المجتمع في اوكرانيا ليس مستعدا
للمفاوضات مع روسيا وروسيا ايضا كما نرى
تقوم بوضع شروط
للمفاوضات انها يجب ان تحقق الاهداف التي
وضعتها امامها في بدايه العمليه العسكريه
الخاصه وبالنسبه لاوكرانيا هذا شيء مستحيل
ليس هناك اي تربه صالحه للمفاوضات هذا شيء
معدوم من المحتمل بعد النجاحات معينه من
قبل اوكرانيا في الجبهات كما
تحدثت الجريده الامريكيه ان بعد ذلك قد
تكون اوكرانيا قريبه من البدء في
المفاوضات ولكن اليوم الرئيس لليلك علق
على مقاله واشنطن بوست وقال اننا نريد ان
نصل لحدودنا القانونيه الدوليه المعترف
بها
وعندها قد نبدا بالمفاوضات ولكن سوف اضيف
من طرفي ان الوصول لهذه الحدود والبدء
بالمفاوضات سوف يكون صعب جدا لان اوكرانيا
فعلا بدات باستعاده الكثير من المناطق
التي كانت احتلت في عام 2014 ولن نتراجع
عن هذا وبالطبع حتى الان ليس هناك نتائج
واضحه
الهجمات المضاده كان هناك محاولات اولويه
اوليه
ويقدروها
مختلف الاطراف بطرق مختلفه البعض يقول
انها لن ليست ناجحه بالدرجه الكافيه ولكن
كما ارى ليس هناك فرصه لهذه المفاوضات بعد
نتائج محدده على ارض المعركه ودينامكيه
هذه الهزيمه سوف نرى
وارحب الان مجددا بضيفي الذين انضم الينا
الانوف الخبير في الشؤون العسكريه
والدوليه
واتحدث عن ما قاله بيرز في محاضر القاها
في انجلترا يوم السبت وقال ان التمرد
المسلح
لزعيم مجموعه فاجنر اظهر ما سماه التاثير
المدمر
لحرب الرئيس
ان تاثير ما قاله زعيم فاجنر وما فعله سوف
يستمر لبعض الوقت وان ذلك سيم ثل تذكيرا
حيا بالتاثير المدمر لحرب بوتين على
مجتمعه ونظامه مؤكدا ان وكالته ستستغل ما
سماه تصاعدا سخط الروس على الحرب في
اوكرانيا لتجنيد عملاء لها في روسيا سيد
يبدو بان سيد ارطمانوف الان لا يسمعنا
ربما اعود اليه
هو موجود معنا الان سيظهر اسالك عن نقاط
التي تحدث بها ويليام مدير الاستخبارات
المركزيه الامريكيه
ومعرفه الاستخبارات المركزيه الامريكيه
ايضا بهذا التمرد المسلح لفقين بريغوجين
في الرابع والعشرين من يونيو حزيران ولكن
عدم مشاركته لهذه المعلومات مع الجانب
الاوكراني في زيارته الاخيره قبل شهر من
وقوع هذه الحادثه الى اي درجه تظهر بان
الحسابات الامريكيه في واشنطن مع موسكو
بخصوص هذا التحرك الداخلي هي ربما حسابات
ايجابيه وتظهر حصن نيه
اعتقد ان ما قام به الامريكيين يثبت انهم
كانوا يريدون ان يعيدوا التوازن
وفي العلاقات مع روسيا
ولكنهم مهتمين باسوء سيناريوهات في روسيا
كانوا ينتظرون الحرب الاهليه كما كان هذا
في عام
1917 لم يشتركوا بالمعلومات مع الطرف
الاوكراني ولكنهم كانوا يراقبه عن بعد
واعتقد انهم كانوا يلعبوا دورا فعالا قد
يكونوا مراقبين ولا يشتركوا مع ولم
يشاركوا الطرف الاوكراني بالمعلومات
ولكنهم كانوا ينتظروا اسوء سينيوريوهات في
المشهد الروسي
ايضا تقييم
موسكو لما خلصت اليه الاستخبارات
الامريكيه على ان هناك سخط هذا التمرد
الذي حدث من قبل مجموعه فاجنر وربما
المعطيات في داخل الروسي عن تاييد ولو
ضمني لبعض القطاعات في المؤسسات
الدوله تعبر عن حاله سخط في الدخل الروسي
لحاله الحرب الروسيه الاوكرانيه
انني قد اخيب ظنك وساقول ان في روسيا
الجامعيين مصرين على الاستمرار في هذه
الحرب وان ان علينا ان ننتصر على الجيش
الاوكراني والبعض يعتقد اننا ليس مواقف
مصره او اعمال فيها اصرار وهذا موقف
فريغوزن كان يريدوا المزيد من الاعمال
الواضحه المزيد من الذخيره والمزيد من
الاعمال العسكريه الصارمه على ما اعتقد
السيد بوتين ووزاره الدفاع عليها موقف
متوازن وغير متعجل وما كانوا يتعجلوا في
تقديم الذخيره او بالقيام بقصفات واسعه
لذلك بريكوزن كان يعتقد ان هذه هذا
التباطؤ كان يؤدي الى سقوط الكثير من
الارواح والجنود ولكن كل الاحزاب يريدون
الاستمرار في العسكريه وليس هناك اي
انقسام في المجتمع ويعتقد الجميع اننا
كاروسيين يجب ان ننتصر في العمليه
العسكريه الخاصه حتى نادي على النظام
الاوكراني حقيقه هو ليس ظني وانما هو
تقييم بيرز الذي سالتك عنه سيد اذهب
للدكتور عناني دكتور عناني
وليمبرز قال في مارس خلال الاشهر السته
المقبله اذا من يعني منذ مارس الى سبتمبر
ستشهد مسار المعارك التحولا على الارض
لصالح الطرف الاوكراني هل لا تزال واشنطن
على ذات القناعه بعد او هذا التقييم على
الارض بعد تباطؤ الهجوم وحاله التممل
الغربي منها
لا اعتقد ذلك اعتقد نحن حالا من شك الغربي
في قدره اوكرانيا على القيام
بصد الهجوم او بقيام بهجوم مضاد يحقق كثير
من المكاسب على الارض وبالتالي الذهاب
للتفاوض كما جاء اليوم
الخطه التي عرضتها
المتعلق باستعاده اكبر قدر من الاراضي
الاوكرانيه لم يتم الحديثه عن استعاده
كامل الاراضي الاوكرانيه لكن قالوا اكبر
قدر الاوكرانيه خاصه في الشرق والجنوب
الامر الثاني متعلق بامكانيه تحريك منظومه
صواريخ ومنظومه دفاع خاصه في القرب من
جزيره الكرم وبالتالي دفع روسيا بشكل
للتفاوض الامر الدخول في التفاوض نهايه
هذا العام اعتقد ان هناك شكوك امريكيه
خاصه في ظل التقدم البطيء والتقدم بطيئه
واسباب جزء منه متعلق بما قامت به القوات
الروسيه بيزرع الحقول الغام كبيره جدا
وجود خنادق مفخخه وبالتالي تصعب من
امكانيه زحف وتقدم نقاط الاوكرانيه باتجاه
الشرق خاصه في مخموت واخرسون الامر الثاني
متعلق عدم وجود يعني وجود اسلحه تبدو
هجوميه لحد بعيد هناك حاله تحافظ من الغرب
باعطاء اوكرانيا على سبيل المثال مثلا
فيما يتعلق بامريكا هناك تحفر هناك تحفظ
ورفض تقريبا او ممانعه في ارسال
طائرات مقاتله 16 وكذلك قنابل عنقوديه
ربما المقبله الموافقه على وجود قنابل
عنقوديه وبالتالي المساعده في الجمله بشكل
او باخر هناك هناك مخاوف امريكيه لان لا
يؤدي الهجوم المضاد الى مكاسب على الارض
وبالتالي تاخير عمليه تفاوض هناك حاله
حاله تملم الامريكيه وغربيه خاصه
الامريكيه بالذات خاصه مع قدوم موسم
الانتخابات هناك حاجه امريكيه لحسم
الموضوع قبل ان تبدا العمليه الانتخابيه
في يناير المقبل وبالتالي انا اتصور سوف
يتم الدفع والضغط الاوكراني من اجل زر
التفاوض باقل قدر من الخسائر الممكنه
السيد اوس اريد تعليقك على مثل هذا الحديث
في ظل حاله شكوك الغربيه والتعثر كما يقول
السيد عناني وكما وهو واضح من التصريحات
الغربيه
من امكانيه تحقيق الجانب الاوكراني تقدم
كبير على الارض
الحديث عن ان الدول الغربيه قد تتملل هذا
كان قد اعلن عنه منذ بدايه الحرب ولكن اذا
عدنا الى عام سابق شهر مايو من السنه
السابقه كان هناك مشكله في الدول الغربيه
انهم لم يكن لديهم ما يكفي من الاسلحه
التي تقدم لاوكرانيا وفي تلك اللحظه
المنتجين للاسلحه امريكا او في اوروبا
كانوا قد توجهوا للدول والحكومات
واعلنوا انهم مستعدين لانتاج اسلحه
حتى يحصلوا على عقود طويله المدى ولقد
حصلوا عليها بعد توقيع هذه العقود شركائنا
قدموا لنا رساله واضحه انهم مستعدين
لدعمنا لفترات طويل طويله وهذا يعني انهم
سوف
انا اعتقد ان في ضوء هذا الوعد انه لن
يقوموا بالضغط على اوكرانيا اللجوء
للمفاوضات اذا بريطانيا على سبيل المثال
دائما تؤكد انها لن لن تضغط على اوكرانيا
الى البدء في المفاوضات عن ذلك في كل مره
اشكرك سيد كبير والباحثين في المعهد
الاوكراني للدراسات الاستراتيجيه حدثتنا
ومن موسكو ايضا اشكر ضيفي الكسندر الخبير
في الشؤون العسكريه والدوليه واشكر ضيفي
من واشنطن دكتور خليل العناني استاذ
العلوم السياسيه والعلاقات الدوليه شكرا
لكم جميعا
لهنا تنتهي هذه الحلقه من برنامج ما وراء
الخبر الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]